je vais vous donner la meilleure chance
possible de tomber enceinte qu'est ce
que vous en dites
vous est entre bonnes mains et
idéalement
démarche chaude
vous êtes enceinte à 100%
salut papa
près d'une femme sur cinq souffre de
dépression près partout pensais pas que
c'était aussi fort la momie brain
vous n'avez pas vous arriver
vous devriez essayer de profiter d'un
peu de calme vous l'avez mérité
[Musique]
souriez lui si
ça rend vraiment plus heureux c'est
prouvé par la science
les risques de complications augmentent
significativement
ses docteurs indoor je me sens pas bien
du tout
confronté en vous ce qui vous bloque
dans votre propre corps
suis parfois elle s'est occupée de me
faire croire que je suis
[Musique]